[Music]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe
I said hey babe hey babe you're gonna be
the one that saves me saves me
and after all
you're my baby boy
hey babe how are you you feel good feel
good what a good name for a band Oasis
yeah it is a good name because when you
think because what is an oasis I think
it's a Well I think it's a Tropical
Paradise is that right I thought it was
an island in and of itself I always
confused the word Oasis and Abyss Abyss
is just a big vacant hole that's right
but Oasis is is is a tropical thing
Oasis is a is a good thing Abyss is a
fun thing too Abyss is good how what
about a band name Abyss
I bet you there is one you think so I
bet you no matter what you say we can
Google and there will be a local band at
least somewhere with that name with that
name yeah because I mean and you know
when you look at Bands A lot of these
bands change their names a hundred times
yeah before they finally before they
finally make it yeah
you heard or the worst band name you've
ever heard the best band name I've ever
heard is the 1975. no the best it is up
there the best band name I think I've
ever heard
um
the best band name like the Beatles is
not a good name the Beatles is not a
it's not the Beatles is not a great I
get that it's b-e-a-t like the beat yeah
I I didn't realize that for a very long
time though what'd you think they were
just after the bug
right I didn't I really truly did not
realize that until one day when I did
right if that makes any sense and I was
like
uh that was a pun on beat now you get it
yeah but I also think that they'll
concede still I mean I'm not one to tell
them what to do the Beatles you know
because then then you can make easy fun
you know fun of it like you know they
have that band The fetals that they play
all Beatles songs with their feet
and it's just you know well you're
kidding though Google the feels please
pull it up thank you
Beatles there it is come on now at the
fetals here you go
um the best band that ever existed how
do you know them they have 600 followers
how do you know about them I'm one of
them
do they not play the music with their
feet did I make that part up did I just
create now get a new band called the
fetals uh yeah the feels are
um a band that uh I thought that they
played Beatles music with their feet but
it seems like it's just a word play on
the name of the band oh it's like the
fake Beetles The Beatles The Beatles the
fake beetles is that what they mean is
that what it is I'm asking you you told
me about the band just moments ago I you
know now I'm confused I don't know the
Sex Pistols is a pretty damn good name
that's a good name the Sex Pistols is a
good name and I when I was in England I
went to Camden uh which is where the Sex
Pistols I believe are from uh and I saw
this big big Sex Pistols in Camden big
Sex Pistols big Amy Winehouse oh they
got Amy Winehouse statues out there you
ever go to Camden England uh I have been
there I believe good time uh you know
I need to start either journaling or
taking a really good note of where I go
because I just let go and I let God
normally and then I and then I and I
don't remember anything I go through the
venues through the back I'm in for a day
I'm out for a day I'm in for a penny I'm
in for a pound and uh sometimes I don't
retain these moments and I learn now
that as I go I wish I did and when you
say something like that it makes me feel
even worse about it actually well first
of all God first Let Jesus Take the
Wheel yeah second of all I want to play
a little game right now of um of fmk uh
fmk with England Scotland Ireland Julia
effing who you Emin who you can
okay the entire nations I'm talking
about everybody in that nation's getting
f'd arcade okay well guys take this in
stride this is a comedic podcast we
don't want letters to the front office
please uh or to our P.O box that we
still haven't gotten yet yes but we
won't need because we've we're being
properly thrown out of the studio that's
correct but join the patreon and please
do
uh I would have to
I know that it's Ireland Scotland UK
Scotland England or UK is not yes you
should
um uh that's right okay so I would have
to I know you love Ireland and I and I
really love it I think the the the the
the the countryside of Ireland is
probably one of the greatest places on
the on in the world
but I think that because I am a
metropolitan type gal I'd probably marry
England I would have I would I would ask
Ireland and no fault of Scotland's own I
would kill them got him yeah just
because yeah well here's the I my answer
just because it's their third out of the
three but not because I have actually I
really like Scotland I spent uh I love
Scott I spent some new I I actually did
walk around Scotland I mixed it up and I
loved it a lot but you know it could
only be one two and three see here's the
thing here's what I'm gonna do is I
actually I'm gonna F I'm gonna I'm gonna
marry I'm gonna M Ireland just because I
love it so much I want to be with it and
Ireland actually had the most Ireland
had the most uh Puerto Ricans that I saw
in the countries that I went Ireland had
the most Puerto Ricans so you know me I
go Puerto Rican oh great because I'm
effing them yeah right you're effort is
fantastic so now you worked out good for
your babies and what I mean they had the
most Puerto Ricans meaning in the entire
nation I saw one Puerto Rican uh but I
still did see one that's one more than
the other two
people's kind of like dude Ireland's
loaded with Ricans now see it's
interesting that was my style yeah well
listen we all people are applauding back
home at what a fine Scottish accent you
have I'm gonna actually F Scotland just
because I think they'd be a really
really really good time yeah I think
they didn't get drunk I think that it'd
be wild F and I'm gonna kill England
just because even though I think it's a
fine country I think England you know
they're the ones who started you know
they were they were an evil empire for a
long time yeah and I think that they're
the ones they they created the idea of
the evil white it's England
oh the evil white came from England the
evil white came from England I mean they
were the evil but although just just
going to that country I love England why
didn't the evil white come from
elsewhere what do you mean what are you
doing Jeremy oh Germany yeah that's good
you know what that's good that's the
evil how about this how about how about
how about Germans now they get a pass
right we don't take anything out of the
Germans now not right Germans walk
around now they look at each other like
what do we do what happened there I
think Germans right now have to I mean
first of all a lot of the kids uh we
wash my hands I don't yeah they're like
that was the guy that was 80 years ago
yeah I don't you know Germans now are
like you know we make weird music yeah
we're all borderline gay like we we
we're we're different Germany right
right now but back in the day Germans
yeah those are probably the most evil
whites um so you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna take back that I'm gonna
actually F England I'm gonna F England F
Scotland I'm gonna F2 of them and I'm
just gonna kill Germany just for the
help you're not getting married I'm not
getting married wow stay true to who I
am it's an archaic principle
um speaking of married you know Johnny
Depp who you know you know big news
trial blah blah blah blah you know he's
going out trial of a lifetime try my
lifetime
Johnny Depp is my new OJ you he is O.J
Simpson I'm gonna tell my kids at O.J
Simpson
now Johnny Johnny Depp is now married uh
is now going out with his lawyer who's a
who's a fine Latina so I heard and I I
got to be honest with you when I was
watching the trial I said ain't no way
they ain't
you knew already I knew it why you saw
them making eyes and stuff because she
spicy Latina and it's very hard to deny
a spicy Latina she's a spot it's very
difficult to uh it's very difficult to
resist the spicy Latina spicy Latina is
one of the hardest things in the in the
world to resist I would agree with you
um
I've had Latinas so spicy that
afterwards I had to take an antacid yes
uh yes that's what I did something yeah
do you think do you think so this they
met they met they they came together
from tragedy I suppose which is what
brings us all together yeah a little bit
of trash yeah a little bit of trash I
always think out after tragedy there's
always a beautiful
yeah I agree you know I saw a rainbow in
Ireland uh there's no way I could have
known that but
it was it was was it one of the rest do
they do they do they have better
rainbows than us probably without it I
mean that's that's it that's the home of
the rainbow
yeah so our driver his name was Phil we
called him Carnage Phil and I said to
Carnage Phil I said please pull over we
need to get a picture of the rainbow uh
and he was like okay and then I pulled
over and and the picture of the the the
rainbow wouldn't come out on the photo
as only as it was almost like it was if
to say you can only view this it was a
vampire rainbow it was it was like yeah
it was like it was it wouldn't come out
at all on the photo and I was so it
never comes out as good I was so upset
because I mean it was a beautiful and I
was eating a dude I ate a scone I ate a
rest stop scone in Ireland best scone
I've ever had in my life blow your balls
off from a rest stop or I mean like pump
and get Cornish fills Pump and Gas and I
went in there and got a scone rest stops
in Ireland different different breed
top top of the line good restaurants
rest stop rest stop they got clean you
the cleansing I can't explain to you how
clean maybe I should move there
do it yeah do it the price you really
the scone do you think the scones were
shipped into the rest stop or you think
someone was in the back whipping them up
the lady told me I said when I said
where do you get the how old are these
scones she goes to uh we just made them
fresh and I said what do you mean you
just made them fresh she goes we make
them right here we pop them in the oven
and we made them fresh
and I was like I'm gonna know right now
give me a death scone and I was messing
with her I said if it's not fresh I
don't pay for it she said you have a
deal
I swear to God and then I took a bite of
that I was about to get my pigs out of
the oven puts it from his piping hot
you're like I'll take ten dollars on let
out a number five yeah and then I was
about to put it on my mouth and she goes
what the hell are you doing and I said I
was gonna take a bite of this phone she
goes you got to put some butter and
jelly on it son uh and then so she put
she put the butter and jelly on it she
goes this is a proper Irish scone and
then I ate it with the butter and the
jelly blew my balls off fresh baked
butter I gave her I gave her I had a 20
Euro thing the scone was I don't know
maybe two dollars three dollars whatever
it was I got one more scones right two
skulls let's say Max five dollars gave
her the whole 20. I said that's for you
oh that's amazing well because I was
crossing over into Northern Ireland I
didn't need the currency right okay so
there was alternative
ulterior motive but still but you both
gave each other uh something and she
said to me you're just throwing money
away and I was like because they don't
the whole tipping thing no it almost
makes them feel like what what we're get
paid like don't insult me yeah don't
insult me but now some will take it but
they're like don't insult me with the
Tipping so it's a very strange thing you
think they are like
we don't do it here
but when I see an American come in I
know I'm gonna get one and I'll take it
that's my thing why not just take the
money they've gotten a taste of it from
Travelers yes I'm surprised that I think
they do a thing where they're all like
we won't you know when you like find
like don't we won't exchange gifts
anymore for Christmas right we're over
that but we know that we love each other
maybe uh the people there are like we we
won't tip each other but when someone
else comes in yeah we take it okay
because they don't say no they don't say
no no I was gonna say no yeah listen we
I spoke about this
uh the other day on my on my Chrissy
chaos patreon but I gotta bring it up to
you did you see the show The Watcher
have you heard about it that sounds
familiar to me do me a favor wait wait
tell me what it is again because I I
watch things and it's a blur to me Bobby
Carnival like Naomi Watts by the way I
had a Naomi Watts weekend this weekend I
literally had a Naomi Watts weekend
that's the name of this episode Naomi
Watts weekend okay Naomi Watts uh is a
name I know like many other people and I
always don't know who she is I know
she's a famous A-list actress but you
know I don't know which I never like
remember what's very difficult to get
Naomi Watson Nicole Kidman right it's
very difficult to play who's who Nicole
came in and they only watched I'm okay
person okay but what has she been in
Naomi the ring big one Naomi the ring
like the original ring the original ring
okay the ring one and two okay it's the
ring two that we could do a whole
episode about how much that movie sucks
I think the worst sequel yeah the I mean
you could tell by the title The Ring two
thumb ring that's ridiculous so dumb
so this is Naomi Watts who's who who
literally Naomi Watts who's she married
to oh she who nobody wants even though
she's not a spicy Latina is sexy enough
let's try but he's awesome
um so Naomi Watson and and and uh but no
me but also says Billy crudup is she
with Billy crudup or leap belief really
crudup is it is it live or leave I think
it's Leah Schreiber live Leah Leah Liev
Liev not to be confused with Kiev yeah
just getting the [ __ ] bomb down again
right now by the drones the Drone why
did you that that should be a project
that we pitched to Russia Ukraine trade
in your drones for scones drones for
scones
make scones not drones merch with the
Ukrainian flag
um let me tell you something babe it's a
watcher starring Bobby Cannavale who I
think is one of the best actors of our
job he's a good Bobby kind of Valley
fantastic Naomi Watts I'm just going to
tell you the premise and then I want you
to watch this at home okay what do you
want because next week I want to talk to
you about this right two weeks from now
I want to talk to you about this give
you two weeks
it is the best television show I've seen
on Netflix in a long
long time it's on Netflix The Watcher
let me give you the prep give me the
Prem
all you got to know a couple moves into
a new house they start getting letter
let me let me just let me just tell you
let me ask you a question right now but
because this is a thriller isn't it
because
if you know anything about me you know
everything about you and you know I know
love nothing more than a good thriller
and let me tell you and I'm going to
tell you the last part that's going to
blow your balls off okay just know a
family okay family moves into a house in
Westfield New Jersey
they move in House of their dreams all
of a sudden they start getting letters
typewritten letters saying that uh the
wa I'm the Watcher I watch this house my
family's watch this house for hundreds
of years the house desires young blood
and they keep getting uh uh letters oh
it's a horror they keep getting letters
all different types of letters all kind
of saying the same thing I Am The
Watcher and it's a freaky voice goes I
Am The Watcher I have watched your house
how do they hear the it's well well you
know all the narration of the show I Am
The Watcher they get the uh their dog
dies in the middle of the house don't
tell me stuff like that well just just
just just one thing that that all these
creepy they feel a presence in the house
the Watcher are you ready for this last
part wait wait don't give anything away
don't knock anywhere please I'm not
getting ready just buckle up okay put
your seatbelt on
okay are you freaked out are you freaked
out I am freaked I already freaked out
yeah can I tell you based on a true
story oh no
no
no
story no are you [ __ ] kidding me no
in Westfield New Jersey Westfield New
Jersey is that where it's from though
yes but that's 57 Boulevard that's
really where it was from yes the house
is still there where's Westfield New
Jersey
I don't know
we is it close is it in the New York
area
the real Watcher wait is that what your
kind yes I think it just passed no
Richard Richard
[Laughter]
no no we we made dinner plans
we literally in the middle of making
amazing dinner plans for next week I
thought that Richard kind was dead I was
telling Jasmine that I love this actor
but he's no longer with us oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] Richard kind oh Westfield New
Jersey is not far oh my God 30 40
minutes are we gonna do a podcast
episode from the steps of 657 Boulevard
West I'll tell you what I'll watch it
I'll watch it and if we and I'm assuming
I'm gonna like it as much as you maybe
we do
um an on location app what do you think
like we'll hook up the car we'll get
richer kind on the app he's in the show
oh we'll get him on the app he'll come
on the app we're gonna do that all right
we gotta do we gotta do that like next
week I'll do it yeah you know what let's
go out there and uh see something you
have to watch the show especially if you
haven't dated with Richard kind yeah Moe
his name is Mo in the show
he's a [ __ ] psycho
lunatic really wait pull up Richard kind
yeah let me
let me hold are you sure you we're
talking about the right guy Richard kind
yeah Richard kind yeah let me tell you
something in the show Looney Tune oh
amazing he sets up his he sets up
I can't look yeah see he's Rich if
you're watching and we know that you are
uh I I need the inside scoop we want the
inside scoop right within the first five
minutes of this show Richard kind is
psychotic you know he looks psychotic oh
I can't wait now I can't wait I need
something I needed a new show you know
what I please watch it the fact that you
know Richard kind we this we will be the
only podcast that gets rich and kind
okay let's do it yeah and can I give you
one back yes this is what I've been
watching now and I am enthralled
the patient the patient yes have you
heard of it is it on Netflix it's on
Hulu Hulu yes via FX the patient I've
heard I've watched the movie The English
Patient but what is the patient it's a
new series it's uh it's it's first
season there's only uh so far there's
been Nine episodes I don't know how many
there are maybe ten I don't know maybe
I'm in for a treat this week with the
season finale I'm not sure right uh the
premise which I usually tell people to
go in cold but did you watch Severance
Severance we talked about this no but I
never watched it
you make sure to watch the way you lay
this on thick I'm telling you Severance
Severance you'll like it I'm gonna give
you two seven the patient Steve Carell
wow I Love Stevie Carrell plays a
therapist okay and this is not giving
anything away really so it's really the
you wouldn't know if you saw like
The Coming Attraction but I I I told you
the way I view stuff now right I go in
cold all the time I don't want to read
it I don't want to hear anything I don't
want to watch the trailer I want to I
don't even want to know if it's a comedy
if it's a I want to watch it and from
the first second be guessing right it
makes it a way better experience anyway
the patient let me take the guessing
away work away for you is um he plays
the therapist and one of his one of his
his his his patience is um
is a serial killer he doesn't know this
and then he literally kidnaps Steve
Carell and holds him hostage
and it's it's it's it's it's really
really really really good like it is
dark tense suspenseful the dude who
plays the serial killer first of all the
two of them no the two of them are
phenomenal if they're not littered with
Awards if they don't if they don't walk
into you know the Kodak Hall during the
Emmys or something and they don't get
hit in the face with an awards I want to
see Steve Carell coming out of the Kodak
Theater bleeding from his head because
they had to give him so hard they hit
him with it I want somebody to beat
Steve Carell's head in with an award
that's what I want that's what I want
you know and this guy too this kid is a
good actor you know who that is I've
seen him before I can't play wait hold
on he is he's riveting what's the kid's
name
yeah this this is an Irish kid wait no
you know what happened this kid's been
in um he's an Irish kid scroll down I
think he was in the movie 1917 he's in
big movies he played a soldier in other
words
the tale the Revenant the little stream
the Revenant I seen him oh the Revenant
that's where I seen him and when he was
the cap yes he was the captain of the um
the the the Dutch West Indies Dutch
company oh that's who it is ex machina
holy [ __ ] I've been watching Nine
episodes of the thing going this guy
looks familiar and I didn't realize he
was an ex machina which by the way I
just met uh is it an ex machina was an
ex machina I thought it was ex machina
until the day I heard it say it said ex
machina who said ex machina I think the
powers would be okay why don't we like
uh
it's I think it takes monkey he's an
Irish kid dude he was creating Xbox I
saw that movie two days two times two
times in the theater next marketer yeah
and the other one what's his name the
other guy in the lead he's in Star Wars
now as well oh he's a star was with him
Oscar uh uh Oscar Isaac Oscar Isaac I
just met him
swell fella said hello little guy or big
guy uh he seemed like an average guy
average size he was a nice guy he was
great in that movie too these so there
you go there's a connection between the
two of them and I mean the Richard Khan
connection is the craziest connection
I've ever heard in my life how so
because I just mentioned the show yeah
and you're having lunch with the guy
next week yeah we yeah we have a dinner
club actually yeah we're having dinner
because you have a dinner club we we
went to dinner and then we all agreed
that everyone at the dinner that we
would start a group text chain and be a
dinner club and we would meet at least
once every couple of months for dinner
and we'd be diligent about it have you
have you kept up with the one time the
second one is they're waiting on me to
give a day who who else is in the dinner
club or you can't say well yeah you
can't say that's do you go to different
restaurants or do you do a home-cooked
meal at somebody's house no no the first
time we went to uh we went uh up Upper
West Side to the Mermaid Inn and we sat
out on the patio out on the front Okay
and we were there for like six hours we
left till we cried right it was better
than cats and uh and anyway so then ever
since then so now we're planning the
second one it's really just it's it's
five people it's not anything crazy it's
good it's good and we got the idea
because he's in multiple dinner clubs
what what is a dinner Club it's people
that keep in touch and meet for dinner
that's literally all it is Richard kind
is and check this out he's just so cool
there's um there's a character actor
group chat that he's in with like 20
famous character actors and whenever any
of them are in each other's Town they'll
text the group and say we're putting
together a dinner and they go like every
month every whatever and he's been doing
for a long time and it's a table full of
all the most like character actors that
you know or whatever it's pretty cool
that's amazing yeah I feel like I yeah
we should get let's play it let's play a
quick guessing game with who the other
at least one other member of Sal's
Dinner Club with Richard kind let me let
me take three guesses it's one of them
Danny Trejo no okay
um is is one of them is one of them JK
Simmons No but I know JK Simmons but
he's not in the dinner Club he's not in
the dinner Club but he is a nice guy and
he he's supportive of yes my final guess
is one of Bono from YouTube No but is it
close is it a musician
was the other person
yeah yeah everybody's an actor well yeah
well
yeah yeah it's two of them yes yes yes
yes yes yes one of them there's only two
it's I mean it's me and the guys and a
couple of people Denzel Washington
ah yes
no but he he might be his
this is is this a game that's not gonna
pay off
it is right
what's up guys big announcement first of
all the IJ tour is going on right now
the pre-sales is going on right now uh
and they go on sale Friday morning uh
which is tomorrow morning and it is the
pre-sale code is IJ Drive we're coming
to a ton of cities so go to
impracticaljokerslive.com for tickets
and then come see your boy uh October
28th I'm in Richmond Virginia October
29th two in Hershey in Pennsylvania and
then the following weekend we got
Knoxville November 11th two in Atlanta
on November 12th and Alabama Birmingham
November 13th everything on sale right
now at savacana comedy.com I'll see you
there beautiful beautiful and then I got
a brand new hour of stand-up material go
to chrisdcomedy.com October 27th in
Baltimore November 17th 18 Toronto and
the big one December 31st Huntington
Long Island the Paramount New Year's Eve
show two shows it is on sale tomorrow
tomorrow the presale well it's happening
now uh but it's almost over so it is on
sale tomorrow pre-sale code if you want
is Chrissy Nye uh I believe and uh but
go get those tickets tomorrow
chrisdcomedy.com Amy Schumer I want to
be the New York guy you are I guess I am
I guess you want what you're already
doing sometimes that happens though
right you'll say I want this but you
already have it yeah right that's where
a lot of a lot of things a lot of a lot
of problems happen that way you get
upset about things because because you
you have what you want you already have
it that's where a lot of conflict comes
in and then there's like you're not
you're not content
because you always want more you always
want more but grass green right but a
lot of times a lot that's a lot of time
people get upset they're all upset
they're like what do I want you don't
know what you want because you already
have it
um so why don't you look Inward and just
be content that's what you need to do
yeah instead of always wanting wanting
one and you want to just be satisfied
instead of
wishing
instead of getting upset that you don't
have X Y and Z be happy and grateful
that you do have x y and sure so don't
worry about the things you don't have
but be happy about the things you do
absolutely that's what you got to do I
have been uh this is true I I have been
actually we all know this stuff but I
mean we're going to verify if it's true
pimp you're gonna you're gonna tell me
what he's saying is after he's done
saying it I just want you to say true or
false wait till he's done we're gonna
we're gonna put you to the test now
because you just said this is true and
we need to check that we all know this
but it's hard you know we don't always
put it into practice but I have been
making uh an effort
by the way you know a lot of people say
a concerted effort do you know that they
use that word wrong concerted or effort
a concerted effort some people think
that they I say here is used wrong all
the time it's a little bit of a pet
peeve of mine yeah well concerted effort
means a concentrated group effort on
something you can't make a concerted
effort on your own I think some people
think a concerted effort just means like
extra effort God concentrated effort or
something so your dinner Club is making
your dinner Club is making a concerted
effort that's correct to me yes I'm
making an effort to really really really
slow down
and and really get joy moment to moment
from the absolute smallest things so my
day because is my day is just then
hopefully a string of appreciation of
moments all day long which is you know
we know to do this but we don't do it
like it's just wonderful that we're here
sitting together right now it really is
that we have a podcast I do one of my
best friends we have laughs we enjoy it
we make people happy you know I I had a
a a piece of cinnamon raisins
everybody's happy what's that I don't
know if you've seen the YouTube comments
lately not everybody
yeah you know
sunny today so what do would you say if
you had it's it is uh 12 45 right now
yeah what would you say
12 45 p.m what would you say what time
do you wake up this morning eight eight
Twenty Eight twenty so you've had a bit
over four hours of of waking energy what
has been the happiest moment of your day
today
um I I sat down and I took like 10
minutes of silence I had a glass of
fresh squeezed orange juice and a piece
of cinnamon raisin toast with a little
cream cheese and then I officially
announced the new Impractical Jokers
tour
there it is what's the name drive drive
drive tour drive time yeah I like it
yeah five drives I I I was good we now
we announced it on this morning on the
radio and uh yeah you guys doing Belfast
um we are going to do the island and UK
subsequently but it's not it's not
booked yet subsequently it's another
good word yeah I like that word if you
had to get rid of uh concerted or
subsequently which one would you get rid
of uh subsequently has a queue
I like it when a queue is used yeah
there's no where yeah babes you know it
you know that even though I'm
intermittent fasting when I break that
fast I break it with doordash that's
right you dash it out I'm gonna do this
tonight are you yeah I am yep you're
gonna prove it to me I swear to God I
will send you I will send you a
screenshot I'm gonna post it on my story
yeah okay okay okay that's that's true
that's true all right all right if you
ever pull into a driveway if you're a
trip to the grocery store only to
realize you forgot that one key
ingredient for dinner now you have
options get the groceries you need or a
backup meal from your favorite local
restaurant delivered with doordash I
love it every time you place an order
for pickup or delivery you're setting
off a chain reaction that helps give
back to the people who make your
neighborhood unique that's what I love
so much about this 300 000 Partners you
can support your neighborhood go-to's
which I highly suggest or you can go to
the favorite National restaurants
Popeyes Chipotle Cheesecake Factory and
what about this Slappy along with the
restaurants you love you can now get
groceries and other essential items
delivered with doordash get drinks
snacks and other household items in
under 60 Minutes
babes for a limited time our listeners
can get 50 off up to a twenty dollar
value and zero delivery fees when you
download the doordash app and enter code
hey babe 22. that's 50 off up to a 20
value and zero delivery fees when you
download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code hey babe 22. don't
forget that's code hey babe 22 for 50
off up to a 20 value and zero zero
dollar delivery fees with doordash
subject to change terms apply hey babe
22
now we're from our sponsor betterhelp
disclaimer I already have we have you
ever need ADHD HD right yes
but you're a real psycho
okay love better help a therapist can
help you become a better Problem Solver
making it easy to accomplish your goals
no matter how big or small and sound let
me tell you you need a therapist I do
and that's all we do as people right all
day long if you really break it down we
just have to problem solve all day long
literally and sometimes it can get
really really rough mentions was a
freaking big math problem neither did I
and I better help helps me solve it and
I I haven't solved it but better help is
is making me on the way better help is
like an abacus right of life I I agree
you figure out the problems and then
yeah you push the problems aside aside
yeah because better help and the
therapists and counselors at better help
the highly qualified ones that they
match you with help you solve your life
problems the ones that they match you
with are under in under 48 hours online
where you don't even have to let
yourself be scene if you don't want to
be seen I literally said to them when I
signed up for better up I said there's
no way you can be able to match me up
with a therapist in under 48 Hours you
know what they came in five hours five
hours had a therapist there you go if
you never tried it why not give it a
whirl if you're thinking of trying
therapy better help is a great option
convenient accessible affordable
entirely online when you want to be a
better Problem Solver therapy can help
get you there visit betterhelp.com hey
babe to get 10 off your first month
that's better
help.com hey babe and we're back and
we're back um so James Corden yeah I uh
you know I think sometimes listen
yeah who amongst us has not uh berated
in a server
I actually don't think I've ever berated
a server really you've ever you've never
yelled at a sermon
you're not the kind of guy first of all
I probably I probably there's probably
times my life I should have yelled and I
didn't oh literally I I've never yelled
at a server hey you know you don't want
to hurt a person you could tell you
could tell a person by the way they
treat someone in the services I one time
fired someone in my on my like team or
whatever like you know it was running
like like some numbers for me I fired
them you were running numbers
because of the way he spoke to a
waitress I was like I I just don't like
that energy around me you can't treat
people
always look you got to always look for
the way people treat people they think
they don't need that tells you
everything that's what my mother would
tell me if I was a wee little boy yeah
is how do you treat the people you think
you don't need that tells you everything
you need to know about a person I agree
so I'm always looking for that you treat
people that you think you don't need
badly not on my team bubs I agree
not today because I wouldn't
because I wouldn't think that's the
Watcher
I
number one wouldn't treat a server bad
because you know that he she they it's a
tough job a b they're gonna spit in your
food you think that they brought that
egg omelet out that James Corden yelled
about and was like they didn't do
anything to it yeah have you seen the
movie Waiting it doesn't matter
Balthazar doesn't matter how high of uh
how hot you know top level restaurant
you are what type of Chef anybody could
always you don't know anybody could
always do something to your food yeah
you you think in your life someone's
done something to your food yes I I
think that there's a stat that the
average human or the average American
has eaten something of upwards like a
pound of fecal matter in in their life
or something that's not because people
put it in their food no because there's
microscopic pieces of fecal matter on
people's fingers and then they serve it
to you oh I went like spitefully do you
think anyone's ever done anything
spitefully
I don't know and I've never done
anything when I was a kid I spit in
somebody's sandwich
I I I told this story I think before but
just one time and one time only I Spit
on someone's slice of pizza
it happens it was and it was a woman who
tipped me five pennies
and you spit the pizza then gave it to
them I delivered it yeah this was you
opened it up spitting and then close it
up so we talked about it I don't think
we did did we yeah I used to deliver to
her I went every day she never never
ever ever tipped me I was there this was
a year before I did this and the one day
she finally tipped me she gave me 500
pennies it was 4.95. she said there's
something in there for you I dumped it
out on my boss's counter because he made
me bring it there every day he's like oh
it's big just go bring it I'm like but
it's a waste of our time it's it's just
a slice in a soda and uh and uh yeah and
we counted it I counted it because I
wanted to know what was in there for me
it was five pennies so the next time I
but what is a slice that she wanted a
slice in the soda every day two two
slices uh a few times a week interesting
yeah just two slices of the soda yep two
two
um uh uh Sicilian slices and a can of
Coke you ready for what I'm about to
tell you right now yeah one of the best
slices of pizza I ever had in my life
don't say it Dublin Ireland no way it's
impossible swear to God it's impossible
you know what the name of the place they
don't I I had trouble finding like
I don't love traditional cuisine of the
of the Irish yeah I didn't eat I didn't
assume
well I liked shout out shout out
cuisines
shout out Irish cuisine
it's not for me shout out it's not for
me listen shout out you being honest and
open on who you are and what type of
Cuisine you want to put in your body
that's your right your body your choice
and tell me about the pizza the pizza at
the place was called Bambinos
okay okay so baby right uh Bambinos and
it was right next to a place called the
rolling donut so I did what Bobby Kelly
and Louis C.K coined in their show a
bang bang I went in there with Mr James
matter I had two slices of pizza one
pesto one Margarita sat down with a Diet
Coke the soda by the way in Ireland just
tastes better I don't know what they're
doing the soda's just better Diet Coke
two slices loved it then I went right
next door and got a donut from the
rolling donut and it was a Boston uh uh
Bavarian cream oh wow and I think things
taste better there because they're
closer to Italy and Bavaria they're
fresher
Atlanta gotta go across the Atlantic
see I've been here's what I've been
doing here's what I've been doing is
I've been living my life eating what I
want all in a six hour window oh you've
been doing that I've been doing it
actually you look good what's your
window
so I used to be 16 hours of fasting
eight hours of feeding now I pretty much
go 18 hours of fasting six hours of
feeding because after a month and a half
of 16 fasting eight feeding my stomach I
think has gotten a bit smaller and I
don't even get hungry now we're another
six hours and I now do not eat after 6
PM I don't give a [ __ ] who it is I won't
even eat if your mama come over no way I
can eat past six pm stop and I'd be in
better sleeps I sleep through the night
now so much of the fact where Johnson's
getting mad at me because I'm not waking
up to change the baby oh wow I'm missing
my turn to change the baby okay all
right but I'm like you need to Sleep
Train this little [ __ ] yeah you need a
sweet dream that [ __ ] I saw you she's
gonna ruin your life yeah she could try
to ruin my fast I
um um so so what's the window though
what is the six hours so today so at 12
o'clock if you don't eat it you're gonna
like kill somebody no no no that's the
thing I could just keep going because I
I found that I I have more energy my
energy and it's whatever you want it
shouldn't be whatever I want I try okay
so here's the thing this your fast is
all let me tell you something your fast
is only as good as the food that you use
to break it okay so when you fast what
you want because your cells are ready to
absorb [ __ ] so what you want when you
fast you can't be out here fasting and
then eat some [ __ ] right because
then your cells are going to absorb
[ __ ] right so what you want is
something with that that's got like a
like a like some kind of shell that your
body can break down or a high protein so
you want grilled chicken you want
almonds you want um salmon oh so you're
just talking to superfoods you want
boiled eggs sure you want hard-boiled
eggs because and I'm saying just get
bites of those just do a handful of
almonds and some boiled eggs eat that
then an hour and a half after that when
your body because anything over 30
calories typically breaks a fast
after you eat the handful of almonds and
let's say a hard-boiled egg or a piece
of grilled chicken which is like Bland
whatever [ __ ] then about an hour and
a half after that then you can go
[ __ ] ham do whatever the hell you
want you should I mean listen the
healthier hard as a mother exactly yeah
so you can you should you know obviously
with the healthier the better but like
last night I had a chip witch who gives
a [ __ ]
that should be that slogan
that should be that should be the
commercial
who gives a [ __ ]
so so I I had that and and you know I
woke up today and you know having that
was the last thing I ate but I ate
before six and but I had only consumed
probably 2 000 calories or less I did a
workout baby the other day two days ago
I did 15 pull-ups in a row wow that's a
lot of pull-ups okay let me show your
question
how how
um how how long was it really tough for
that night stretch like at six is six is
Hurley so especially if you go to bed
like I on a normal on when my life is
normal I go to bed about midnight right
so that would be six hours but I bet you
I swear to God you know what I've been
doing Factor
where they deliver the meals I've been
I've been doing Factor right and I swear
to God they feel good right yeah yeah I
need I eat one and I'm full I believe it
for hours and hours and hours and then
like I and then I like have another one
right but like but I'm like let me have
enough but two of those a day could do
me good I've been using this app called
zero and it really is just like a timer
and they have a lot of
um they have a lot of like uh uh talks
that they give every day so I listen to
some of those but it's really it's just
like accountability like I don't want to
lie to the app so like the zero fasting
app it's like once I put I'm starting to
fast now I don't want to touch it again
until after 16 hours minimum and I don't
want to lie to it and say that uh and
say that I didn't eat when I ate because
it's giving you all these like thumbs up
you're doing great and so I don't want
so it's like this accountability yeah
but the three things that I've been
doing you ready for this the three
things I'll never be ready for it like
legitimate life-changing I mean I'm
getting I'm 38 so it's like I've come to
the kind of realization and just accept
it's like I'm not going to be ripped I'm
never going to look like I did when I
was 19 unless I do a little testosterone
steroids which could still be on the
table okay but take nothing off the
table it's about so it's weird my weight
right is still about 225.
227 sometimes but it's a different body
but my dude babes I have to wear a belt
with size 36 now you know me I have my
special size 38 I can probably get my
get my get my little fasting ass into a
34. it'll still be tight but I can get
in there and my clothes everything like
I'm a different type of two 25 but the
three things I've been doing is fasting
either the 16 8 18 6 I try to stay
healthy but a lot of times I go after
results
second thing ready for this delaying
coffee
I don't drink coffee now until 90
minutes to 120 minutes an hour and a
half to two hours after I wake up
because the chemicals
when you wake up isn't coffee a
suppressant though coffee what it all it
does is trick your brain I forgot what
the chemical is called but it stops I
think it's like Adina so something with
an a basically that's the thing that
that chemical in in you know when our
brains when we wake up like our brains
still have that chemical in us that are
like slowly getting lower and lower and
lower to like you know saying you're
basically your type what is it um
uh the chemical uh coffee tricks but no
do coffee do do waking up waking up
hormone begins with an a hormone begins
with an a something like that
yeah
or begins with an a
quarter no it's not cortisol it's
there's another that cortisol is
involved cortisol is definitely involved
but there was another hormone adenos so
something like tell us what it is write
in the YouTube comments I know there's
people out there that know exactly what
it is and you're yelling at the TV
saying what an [ __ ] am so just tell
us what it is I'll find it and text it
to you
um but and you know I'd love to honestly
bring it up at the dinner Club if I
could get an invite
um and um no it's not epinephrine it's
Begin Again with an A but anyway when we
wake up right
your chemicals in you know as we're
naturally waking up you're you're you're
retired and this this chemical that
begins with the a is very high and then
it slowly gets lower naturally and then
we should wake up our bodies will wake
ourselves up what the [ __ ] but you're
still but that's the chemical that makes
you tired what coffee does is just stops
that chemical from getting it just stops
it it's it's it it basically throws it
out the window so you get like this fake
wake up that's why you crash a lot
because it hasn't matched in the
afternoon because it hasn't naturally
went down okay but if you can just if
you could just hold on for two hours
which I've been doing you get I got a
little bit of headaches the first couple
of days but quit but it's not like I'm
not saying no to coffee so I can deal
with a headache for 30 minutes because I
know the coffee I'm a very casual coffee
drinker so you don't need the coffee so
the people out there need the coffee if
you delay the coffee that's it I I felt
like now I've only need one cup of
coffee a day maybe sometimes two or used
to be five to six especially doing pods
working out whatever the third thing
third cold showers
but I don't do the whole thing of a cold
shower I'll do uh five minutes let's say
let's say I'm washing my neck let's say
I'm washing my butt naked body yeah five
minutes the last for four minutes it's
warm the last minute 30 seconds to a
minute called okay when you say cold
cold as [ __ ] no you don't just mean not
hot no I mean freezing to the point
where you have to do deep breaths in
through your nose and mouth to get
through it because here's what happens
mentally you you subconsciously tell
yourself I can get through anything
today if I just got through that pain uh
of the culture is this coming from you
or this is something you read it's red
backed by research the second thing that
it does it actually stimulates a
cortisol uh stress response so stress
has got a negative connotation people
say stress is bad and for the most part
it is but when you stress your body in a
controlled way like that it's like
taking a plunge pool punch exactly
plunge pool what happens is your body
then reacts to stress a lot better and
can kill viruses and things like that a
lot quicker there's been studies linked
to people who take cold showers every
day get less sick they get less flus and
less colds that really don't yeah but
you have to get that listen that study
could be on some [ __ ] yeah but for
the from what I read right that's it's
been helpful even though I do have a
cold right now yeah yeah you sound like
it's working
um but you have to get all the soap off
of you before you hit with the cold the
cold don't you jack [ __ ] to the soap so
what I do is I want cold water is not
good for anything
except that well so what I'm like when
you're showering right it's not pleasant
so what I do is I wash my body I you
know I wash everything I wash my balls
my everything my [ __ ] my armpit by
the way fun fact with uh with um washing
your body you really only have to wash
your armpits your general and your butt
so they have to wash other parts of your
body right that's what it actually don't
have Ashton Kutcher and Mila Kunis do
that yeah just just your pits your your
butt and and your gems yeah
that's I you know what you know what I
may call me crazy I do it all I do it
all if I'm doing those if you're in
there I extend it the extra minute clean
the whole body do it yeah I'm not I'm
not I'm not going to tell you you can't
do that yeah all right unless you want
me to show up in the showers with you
then I'll monitor right but
the cold shower at the so I wash my body
the last thing I do is I turn it as cold
as I can deal with it and then I just
try to hang on for 30 seconds to a
minute I try and you and you've been
doing that every shower I've been doing
that now you know it's coming are you
dreading it are you now on the side of
where like I can get through this
because I know it energizes me when I'm
out it hurts the same way today as it
did when I started
I take a big deep breath and I just say
hold on for as long as you can some days
I can hold on longer head underneath or
just hit me in the tits all right so I
read as long as it's hitting you on the
back of your neck and head it should be
do the whole body I know there's other
theories out there
um and you just go there like and you're
just shivering going you're making noise
yeah yeah I'm like trying to just get
through it like do the ice baths the ice
pass I would do if I had so there's one
place that has um uh uh it's in the city
I forgot what it's called but they have
a sauna a steamer and then an ice bath
and you're supposed to do the steamer
and then jump in the ice air air Spa
area that's what it is I've been there
yeah yeah so you're supposed to do that
but I don't have the room for an ice
bath if I had the capability like I know
Rogan has eyes pass I would do ice baths
wow so for now the only thing I could do
is a cold shower when you get out of the
shower after the freezing cold you're
not cold out of the shower right it's
almost like you because it doesn't the
skin get like the blood rush to the skin
I I warm up quicker but because I have a
warm water on my body well warm water on
my body uh uh you know for extended
period of time for four minutes the cold
feels colder so let's say I'm putting my
temperature down to 50 degrees to end
the shower that 50 degrees feels like 30
degrees to me because my my right you
know right uh body is warm but if I just
start off with the cold shower which I
should be doing but I'm too much of a
puss I'm a left I'm just a big [ __ ]
I would be able to tolerate 50 degrees
water more but you won't you can't take
a full shower cold like I said it
doesn't take the soap off it doesn't
take the soap off yes it does it's water
um I tell you cold water takes the soap
off not ice cold water I think it's it
doesn't really like it comes off better
with easier with hot water well I think
just because you can tolerate it well
think about that do you wash your dishes
in cold water why
because of the germs of germs it gets it
off but doesn't it sanitizes it better
okay because it really doesn't make a
difference really well for me in my
experience the soap doesn't come off in
the cold water that well
you know I took a bath this weekend
to full bath yeah I did do you have a
bathtub I I do but I was on the road I
was in Canada this weekend oh really
yeah I got I got the new hotel for you
it's dope what city I was in Hamilton
and toronts you got the new hotel for me
in Toronto yep okay it's off the chain
really all right I haven't booked yet I
had a nice deep soaking tub are they
marrying up on point members
um no they're not but you'd be surprised
who are and you don't know it
Ritz Carlton's married bomb boy case in
point there you go uh I I drew a bath
and I said a lot of times I'll see a
nice the the the the bathroom will be
nice and I'll be like this weekend I'm
gonna take a bath a bath is fun fun and
when's the last time you took a bath I
take a bath I get in the bath with my
kid okay she still wants me to yeah so
we'll get in the bath yeah I think it's
wonderful anyway they had some bath
salts I threw it the [ __ ] in there yeah
and I got in I was is this a 20-minute
soak before the show oh Rejuvenation
forget about it relaxed
uh but what happened to me was but uh my
feet and legs were cold and I put a hot
bath and so I stepped into the bath and
because my feet and legs were very cold
and the bathrooms borderline like just
about too hot I I really really really
almost hurt myself badly because because
I couldn't take the change in
temperature that quickly because my feet
I really thought my feet and legs were
gonna fall off because it was so hot or
so cold the water was hot and my body
was so cold that you couldn't it was a
shock like you know it was shocked I had
to jump out jump I leapt out of the bath
and I had to take a time outside yeah
Dead with the jump out Toronto is a good
City Canada is a good country let's talk
about Canada I love Canada Canada Shadow
Canada Shanna providences shout out all
that stuff
Canada if you're listening and we know
that you are I we love you and a quick
flight from a one-hour flight to Toronto
Toronto is a sixth barrel I'm telling
you right now Toronto is if you've never
been in Toronto it is freaking awesome I
I love it there I love I've been there
about five times I I love this city
there's an energy in that City and we
got a new hotel they got culture there
they got cool things to do there they're
good questions right there they're a
good Christmas Town you've been in
Toronto for Christmas yeah I'll be in
Toronto November 17th to the 18th if
people want to come oh yeah
christycomedy.com because you already
did it so yeah yeah are you going to
Queen Elizabeth uh no I'm doing uh the
Royal okay in the Little Italy okay oh
it's still very Regal yeah Queen
Elizabeth I'm doing the Royals God Bless
yeah he's in Queens we're still in the
corner you should have told me I would
have announced it on stage yet I didn't
realize we're going there yeah um but
Toronto and it's a good news oh I got
some good restaurants for you too babe I
ate at a place called Patois
it came as a wreck Patois being the
Jamaican speak Patois it was Jamaican
Chinese
Fusion did you have jerk chicken I did
bro wow I had like jerk chicken like uh
pad like uh uh jerk chicken
what's that what's that like uh stir fry
yeah but the noodles the noodles jerk
chicken lo mein yeah had that I had I
had amazing amazing dishes what kind of
desserts do they have I didn't get it
any dessert I didn't get any dessert I
had an unsweetened iced tea with natural
Peach flavor
I had a cauliflower dish I had a
Brussels sprout dish I had a jerk
chicken dish we had a Smash Burger we
divided amongst the table that was
really nice who are you with was Richard
I was with Jay Larson okay Richard Kong
was not at this like Jay Larson very
tall shout out Jay Larson
fine and Chris Johnson
you know who I love
you oh just as we walked around we went
to uh we went to the um the Kensington
Market have you been there uh no I
haven't but I opened all these um I I
cannot wait to get to Toronto there's a
distillery in Toronto and during
Christmas time they turn into a
Christmas Village have you been there in
and out yeah and I walk around I got
some spiked hot apple cider you're
playing carols oh it's it's it's it's
Christmas spirit up your ass so when I
go to Toronto I'm going to Toronto and
then the very next day Toronto is
November 17th 18th and the very next day
is Buffalo I'm getting to Toronto
November 16th because I'm gonna go see
Heat Raptors in Toronto amazing then
November 18th I'm gonna stay one extra
day already approved with the family
one XJ you see Buffalo Bills in Buffalo
um which I heard is Bill's Mafia you
gotta see it you got to experience it
and then right after the game it's one
o'clock game driving home to New York
from Buffalo six hours just gonna drive
oh wow it's gonna drive because by the
time I get on the flight is it six hours
just six I'll check that you think it's
more I would check it and you coming on
a Monday or you oh that's Sunday Sunday
that's smart yes yeah those Mafia by the
way they they beat they you know they
beat this week the Bills beat the Chiefs
the chief they beat Patrick home and the
Chiefs and that's a solid organization
yeah they have a lot in front of them
you know who else lost
this week Tom Brady Tom Brady lost two
Pittsburgh Steelers steal his baby they
lost to the Pittsburgh Steelers Tom
Brady still 45 still the oldest person
in the NFL still it is and Tom Brady
he's lost not only a football game but
he's also lost his wife is that true uh
yeah I never know if it's just like
Tabloid they said they said that it is
over
really and is it because he came out of
retirement I think that's what it is
that really really and they're three and
three
it's not good you want to come out of
retirement and at least go 16-0 yeah
yeah and keep your wife I keep your wife
is what I'm saying but shout out Tom
Brady shout out Tom Brady man who's
never had a strawberry
you said that he's never had a
strawberry in his whole life
strawberries today have you seen him
handsome he looks svelt spelled yeah I
guess he's like I feel like he's like a
bionic man right he is he just has like
a billion dollars and he puts it right
into his body somehow yeah he takes cold
showers he probably definitely does that
that boy that boy good Tom Brady good
boy running around the field with 20
year olds twice his size
that boy good boy good tell me the hotel
I need to stay at in Toronto this has
been hey babe
[Music]
hey
[Music]